NASA could make history today if its
latest Mars Lander successfully touches
down on the Red Planet for the first
time scientists will study not just the
planet's surface but also its core the
insight Lander is set to land just
before 3 p.m. Eastern Time after
traveling almost 300 million miles Jamie
yuccas is at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory in Pasadena California Jamie
good morning good morning this is a
scale model of the spacecraft its
wingspan is 19 feet long that's about
the size of a 1960s convertible only 40%
of the last 44 missions to Mars have
been successful and this Lander will
face temperatures in the thousands
before touching down after six and a
half months of space travel insights big
day is finally here years of hard work
will come down to seven crucial minutes
it's called the seven minutes of Terror
because is everything has to go
perfectly in the seven minutes from the
top of the atmosphere down to landing
this spacecraft will enter Mars's
atmosphere at more than 12,000 miles per
hour heating the vessel shields to some
2,700 degrees it will slow to less than
300 miles per hour
once the parachute is deployed then it
will release its heat shield three legs
will pop out and small rockets will slow
the spacecraft to about three miles per
hour before it lands so we can't control
the vehicle on earth we can't use a
joystick to land the computer on board
the spacecraft has to do everything
perfectly to get it to the surface over
the coming months the Landers robotic
arm will deploy one device to monitor
seismic activity and another to dig
sixteen feet below the planet's surface
to measure Mars's internal temperature
have lots of missions that have looked
at the outside but one of the big
unknowns is what does the inside look
like whether the core is solid or liquid
those types of questions are really
important for understanding how the
planet would it look like when it first
formed and how I got
where it is today because Mars and Earth
were created from the same materials
billions of years ago scientists say
studying Mars's interior could help them
understand how earth was formed and
later evolved the mission will also
allow them to learn more about the
safest way to enter Mars's atmosphere
and land to prepare for the next big
step in exploring the planet better we
understand that environment at Mars what
Mars is like and how we can land we'll
be better prepared to send humans to
Mars in the future
the first job for the lander will be to
take a photo of the planet's surface
once that happens is going to get very
loud in here people say it sounds like
the winning touchdown of the Super Bowl
when that happens and the spacecraft
will be very busy over the next Martian
year which for us Nora means November of
2020 so cool Jamie thank you we should
mention you can see live coverage of the
landing on our streaming network cbsn
that is just before 3 p.m. Eastern this
afternoon and I know some people at this
table are going to be watching my
six-year-old will be now yeah and
waiting for that first transmission of
the picture because there will be a
period where they know it will have
started but they won't have gotten the
confirmation of the picture and that's
when everybody will be up on tiptoe okay
because I'm trying to think now what's
the terror part it's for the announcer
control room that everything I go right
sorry that the Perry's want them to be
spared the sad tear that the picture
might not come through well I like to
see NASA get excited so let's see how
this all turns out